this piece by the marine band
trio from hail america
the marine band known as the president's
own they play at the
pleasure of the president and the
commandant the marine corps
and they've played at every inauguration
since jefferson's
[Music]
greeting former president of epa dan
quayle
look at his eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
that's a phrase that is well welcomed
right now
let's enjoy the ceremony
please welcome the honorable amy
klobuchar
[Applause]
vice president pence mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect members of
congress
and the judicial branch former
presidents and first ladies
vice presidents leaders from abroad and
a whole bunch of bidens
america welcome to the 59th presidential
inauguration
where in just a few moments joe biden
and kamala harris
will take their solemn oaths
this ceremony is the culmination of
244 years of a democracy
it is the moment when leaders brought to
this stage by the will of the people
promised to be faithful to our
constitution to cherish it and defend it
it is the moment when they become as we
all should be
guardians of our country have we become
too jaded
too accustomed to the ritual of the
passing of the torch of democracy
to truly appreciate what a blessing
and a privilege it is to witness this
moment
i think not two weeks ago
when an angry violent mob staged and
insurrection
and desecrated this temple of our
democracy
it awakened us to our responsibilities
as americans this is the day
when our democracy picks itself up
brushes off the dust and does what
america
always does goes forward as a nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
this conveyance of a sacred trust
between our leaders and our people
takes place in front of this shining
capital dome
for a reason when abraham lincoln gave
his first inaugural address
in front of this capitol the dome was
only partially constructed braced by
ropes of steel
he promised he would finish it he was
criticized for spending
funds on it during the civil war to
those critics he replied
if the people see the capital going on
it is a sign we intend the union
shall go on and it did and it will
generations of americans gave their
lives to preserve our republic in this
place
great legislation to protect civil
rights and economic security
and lead the world was debated and
crafted
under this dome dome now it falls on all
of us
not just the two leaders we are
inaugurating today
to take up the torch of our democracy
not as a weapon
of political arson but as an instrument
for good
we pledge today never to take our
democracy for granted
as we celebrate its remarkable strength
we celebrate its resilience
its grit we celebrate the ordinary
people doing extraordinary things for
our nation
the doctors and nurses on the front line
of this pandemic
the officers in the capitol a new
generation
never giving up hope for justice we
celebrate a new president joe biden
who vows to restore the soul of america
and cross the river of our divides to a
higher plane
and we celebrate our first african
american first asian american
and first woman vice president
kamala harris who stands on the
shoulders of
so many on this platform who have
forged the way to this day when she
takes the oath of office
little girls and boys across the world
will know that anything
and everything is possible and in the
end
that is america our democracy
a country of so much good and today
on these capital steps and before
this glorious field of flags we
rededicate
ourselves to its cause
thank you
it is now my honor to
introduce to you the senator who has
worked with me and so many others
to make this ceremony possible my friend
and the
chair of the inaugural committee
missouri senator
roy blunt
well i should have known when senator
klobuchar got involved at least there'd
be a touch of snow
up here this morning of
all the things we'd considered i don't
think snow was on my agenda until i
walked out the door
a moment ago but thank you senator
klobuchar and thanks to the other
members
of the joint congressional committee on
the inauguration as we
officially begin the 59th inaugural
ceremony
i also want to thank the joint committee
staff and our partners particularly our
security partners
for the they the way they've dealt with
unprecedented
circumstances when i chaired the
inauguration four years ago i shared
president reagan's
1981 description of this event as
commonplace
and miraculous commonplace because we've
done it
every four years since 1789
miraculous because we've done it every
four years
since 1789. americans have celebrated
this moment during war
during depression and now during
pandemic
once again all three branches of our
government come together as the
constitution
envisions once again we renew our
commitment
to our determined democracy forging a
more perfect union
that theme for this inauguration are
determined democracy
forging a more perfect union was
announced by the joint committee before
the election
with the belief that the united states
can only fulfill its promise
and set an example for others if we are
always working
to be better than we have been the
constitution established that determined
democracy with its first three words
declaring the people as the source of
the government
the articles of confederation hadn't
done that the magna carta hadn't done
that
only the constitution says the
government exists
because the people are the source of the
reason
it exists they immediately followed
those first three words
with the words to form a more perfect
union
the founders did not say to form a
perfect union
they did not claim that in our new
country nothing would need to be
improved fortunately they understood
that always working to be better
would be the hallmark of a great
democracy
the freedoms we have today
the nation we have today
is not here just because it happened
uh and they aren't complete a great
democracy working through the successes
and failures of our history striving to
be better than it had been
and we are more than we have been and we
are
less than we hope to be the assault on
our capital at this very place just two
weeks ago
reminds us that a government designed to
balance and check
itself is both fragile
and resilient during the last year the
pandemic challenged our free and open
society and called for extraordinary
determination
and sacrifice and still challenges us
today
meeting that challenge head on have been
and are health care workers scientists
first responders essential frontline
workers
and so many others we depend on in so
many ways
today we come to this moment people all
over the world
as we're here are watching and we'll
watch what we do here
our government comes together the
congress and the courts join the
transition
of executive responsibility one
political party more pleased today
and on every inaugural day than the
other
but this is not a moment of division
it's a moment of unification
a new administration begins and brings
with it
a new beginning and with that our great
national debate goes forward
and a determined democracy will continue
to be
essential in pursuit of a more perfect
union and a better future
for all americans what a privilege for
me to join you
today thank you
i'm pleased to call to the podium a long
time friend of the president-elect and
his family father leo
o'donovan to lead us in an invocation
please stand if you are able and remain
standing for the national anthem
and the pledge to our flag
thank you
gracious and merciful god
at this sacred time we come before you
in need
indeed on our knees
but we come still more with hope and
with our
eyes raised anew to the vision of a more
perfect union
in our land a union of all our citizens
to promote the general welfare
and secure the blessings of liberty to
ourselves
and our posterity we are a people
of many races creeds and colors
national backgrounds cultures and styles
now far more numerous and on land much
vaster
than when archbishop john carroll wrote
his prayer
for the inauguration of george
washington
232 years ago
archbishop carroll prayed that you
o creator of all would assist with your
holy spirit of counsel
and fortitude the president of these
united states that his administration
may be conducted in righteousness
and be eminently useful to your people
today we confess our past failures to
live
according to our vision of equality
inclusion and freedom for all
yet we resolutely commit still more now
to renewing the vision
to caring for one another in word and
deed
especially the least fortunate among us
and so becoming a light for the world
there is a power in each and every one
of us that lives
by turning to every other one of us a
thrust of the spirit to cherish
and care and stand by others and above
all those
most in need it is called
love and its path is to give ever more
of itself
today it is called american
patriotism born not of power
and privilege but of care for the common
good
with malice toward none and with charity
for all for our new president
we beg of you the wisdom solomon sought
when he knelt before you and prayed for
an understanding heart
so that i can govern your people and
know the difference
between right and wrong we trust in the
counsel of the letter of james
if any of you likes wisdom you should
ask god who gives generously to all
without finding fault
and it will be given to you
pope francis has reminded us how
important it is to dream together
by ourselves he wrote we risk seeing
mirages
things that are not there dreams on the
other hand
are built together
be with us holy mystery of love
as we dream together
help us under our new president to
reconcile the people of our land
restore our dream and invest it with
peace
and justice and the joy that is
the overflow of love
to the glory of your name forever
amen
ladies and gentlemen please remain
standing for the presentation of our
national colors
by the armed forces color guard the
singing of our national anthem
and for the pledge of allegiance
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen here for the
singing of our national anthem
accompanied by the president's own
united states marine band
please welcome lady gaga
[Music]
oh say can you
see
[Music]
we
[Music]
and bright stars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
still
[Music]
is
[Music]
me
[Music]
we're ready
ladies and gentlemen please welcome from
the city of south fulton georgia fire
and rescue department president
of the international association of
firefighters local 3920
fire captain andrea m hall for the
reciting of the pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance
to the flag of the united states
of america and to the republic
for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible
with liberty and justice for all
[Applause]
what you are all about to be part of
america
is a historic moment of firsts
to administer the oath to our first
african-american our first asian
american and our first woman vice
president
kamala harris it is my great privilege
to welcome to the inaugural stage the
first latina
to ever serve on the supreme court of
the united states of america
justice sonia sotomayor
ladies and gentlemen please remain
standing for the oath of office followed
by musical honors
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i kamala davey harris do solemnly swear
i kamala davey harris who soundly swear
that i will support and defend
the constitution of the united states
and i will support
and defend the constitution of the
united states against
all enemies foreign and domestic against
all enemies
born and domestic that i will bear true
faith and allegiance to the same
that i will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same that i take this
obligation
freely and i take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion without any mental
reservation
or purpose of evasion that i will well
and faithfully discharge
that i will well and faithfully discard
the duties of the office on which i am
about to enter
the duties of the office upon which i am
about to enter
so help me god so help me god all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
please welcome jennifer lopez to perform
this land as your land
and america the beautiful accompanied by
members of the president's own
united states marine band
wow
this land is your land
[Music]
this land is mine
from california
to the new york islands
from the redwood forest
to the gulf stream world
this land was made for you
and me as i went walking
down
[Music]
this land was made for you and me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
from
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
this land was made
for you and
[Laughter]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
well that was great the sun is shining
and mr
president-elect this is the first
inauguration
in the history of america where j-lo was
the warm-up act for chief justice
roberts
with that it is now my distinct honor
to introduce the chief justice of the
supreme court of the united states
john roberts to administer the
presidential oath
to the next president of the united
states
joseph r biden
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please stand for
the oath of office followed by musical
honors
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
that i will faithfully execute and i
will faithfully execute
the office of president of the united
states office of president of the united
states
and will to the best of my ability the
world to the best of my ability
preserve protect and defend deserve
protect and defend
the constitution of the united states
constitution of the united states so
help you god
so help me god congratulations mr
[Applause]
president
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
yes
hmm
my fellow americans a moment
we have all been waiting for
it is now my great privilege and high
honor to be the first person to
officially introduce the 46th
president of the united states joseph
r biden jr
chief justice roberts
vice president harris
[Applause]
[Music]
speaker pelosi leader schumer
mr mcconnell vice president pence
and my distinguished guest my fellow
americans
this is america's day
this is democracy's day a day of history
and hope
of renewal and resolve through a
crucible
for the ages america has been tested
anew
and america has risen to the challenge
today we celebrate the triumph not of a
candidate
but of a cause the cause of democracy
the people the will of the people
has been heard and the will of the
people has been heeded
we've learned again that democracy is
precious
democracy is fragile at this hour my
friends
democracy has prevailed
so now on this hallowed ground where
just a few days ago
violence sought to shake the capital's
very foundation
we come together as one nation under god
indivisible to carry out the peaceful
transfer of power as we have for more
than two centuries
as we look ahead in our uniquely
american way
restless bold optimistic
and set our sights on the nation we know
we can be
and we must be i thank my predecessors
of both parties
for their presence here today i thank
them from the bottom of my heart
and i know
i know the resilience of our
constitution
and the strength the strength of our
nation
as does president carter who i spoke
with last night who cannot be with us
today
but whom we salute for his lifetime in
service
i've just taken the sacred oath each of
those patriots
have taken the oath first sworn
by george washington but the american
story
depends not on any one of us not on some
of us
but on all of us on we the people
who seek a more perfect union
this is a great nation we are good
people and over the centuries through
storm and strife
in peace and in war we've come so far
but we still have far to go
we'll press forward with speed and
urgency for we have much to do
in this winter of peril and significant
possibilities
much to repair much to restore
much to heal much to build and much to
gain
few people in our nation's history have
been more challenged
or found a time more challenging or
difficult
than the time we're in now once in a
century virus
that silently stalks the country has
taken as many lives in one year
as america lost in all of world war
ii millions of jobs have been lost
hundreds of thousands of businesses
closed
a cry for racial justice some 400 years
in the making
moves us the dream of justice for all
will be deferred no longer
a cry for survival comes from planet
itself
a cry that can't be any more desperate
or any more clear and now
a rise of political extremism white
supremacy
domestic terrorism that we must confront
and we will defeat
[Applause]
to overcome these challenges to restore
the soul and secure the future of
america
requires so much more than words
requires the most elusive of all things
in a democracy
unity unity
in another january on new year's day in
1863
abraham lincoln signed the emancipation
proclamation
when he put pen to paper the president
said and i quote
if my name ever goes down into history
it'll be for this act and my whole
soul is in it
my whole soul is in it today
on this january day my whole soul is in
this
bringing america together uniting our
people
united in our nation and i ask every
american to join me
in this cause
uniting to fight the foes we face
anger resentment and hatred extremism
lawlessness violence disease
joblessness and hopelessness with unity
we can do great things important things
we can right wrongs we can put people to
work in good jobs we can teach our
children
in safe schools we can overcome the
deadly virus
we can reward reward work and rebuild
the middle class and make health care
secure for all
we can deliver racial justice and we can
make america once again
the leading force for good in the world
i know speaking of unity can sound to
some like a foolish fantasy these days
i know the forces that divide us are
deep and they are real
but i also know they are not new
our history has been a constant struggle
between the american ideal that we're
all are created equal
and the harsh ugly reality that racism
nativism fear demonization
have long torn us apart
the battle is perennial and victory is
never assured
through civil war the great depression
world war 9 11
through struggle sacrifice and setbacks
our better angels
have always prevailed
in each of these moments enough of us
enough of us
have come together to carry all of us
forward
and we can do that now history
faith and reason show the way
the way of unity we can see each other
not as adversaries but as neighbors
we can treat each other with dignity and
respect
we can join forces stop the shouting and
lower the
temperature for without unity
there is no peace only bitterness and
fury
no progress only exhausting outrage
no nation only a state of chaos
this is our historic moment of crisis
and challenge
and unity is the path forward
and we must meet this moment as the
united
states of america if we do that
i guarantee you we will not fail we have
never
ever ever ever failed in america
we've acted together and so today
at this time in this place let's start
afresh
all of us let's begin to listen to one
another again
hear one another see one another
show respect to one another politics
doesn't have to be a raging fire
destroying everything in its path
every disagreement doesn't have to be a
cause for total
war and we must reject the culture
in which facts themselves are
manipulated
and even manufactured
my fellow americans we have to be
different than this
america has to be better than this and i
believe america is so much better than
this just look around
here we stand in the shadow of the
capitol dome
as was mentioned earlier completed amid
the civil war
when the union itself was literally
hanging in the balance
yet we endured we prevailed here we
stand
looking out on the great mall where dr
king spoke
of his dream here we stand we're 108
years ago
at another inaugural thousands of
protesters tried to
block brave women marching for the right
to vote
and today we mark the swearing-in of the
first woman in american history
elected to national office vice
president kamala harris
don't tell me things can't change
here we stand across the potomac from
arlington cemetery
where heroes who gave the last full
measure of devotion
rest in eternal peace and here we stand
just days after a riotous mob thought
they could use violence to silence the
will of the people
to stop the work of our democracy to
drive us from this sacred ground
it did not happen it will never happen
not today not tomorrow not ever
not ever
to all those who supported our campaign
i'm humbled by the faith you've placed
in us
to all those who did not support us let
me say this
hear me out as we move forward take a
measure of me and my heart
if you still disagree so be it
that's democracy that's america
the right to dissent peaceably in the
guard rails of our republic is perhaps
this nation's
greatest strength yet hear me clearly
this agreement must not lead to disunion
and i pledge this to you i will be a
president for
all americans all americans
and i promise you i will fight as hard
for those who did not support me
as for those who did
[Applause]
many centuries ago saint augustine
a saint of my church wrote to the people
was a multitude
defined by the common objects of their
love
defined by the common objects of their
love
what are the common objects we as
americans love
that define us as americans i think we
know
opportunity security
liberty dignity respect honor
and yes the truth
recent weeks and months have taught us a
painful lesson
there is truth and there are lies
lies told for power and for profit
and each of us has a duty and a
responsibility
as citizens as americans and especially
as leaders
leaders who have pledged to honor our
constitution
and protect our nation to defend the
truth
and defeat the lies look
i understand that many of my fellow
americans view the future
as fear and trepidation i understand
they worry about their jobs i understand
like my dad they lay a bed staring at
the at night staring at the ceiling
wondering
can i keep my health care can i pay my
mortgage
thinking about their families about what
comes next
i promise you i get it
but the answer is not to turn inward to
retreat into competing factions
distrusting those who don't look like
look like you
or worship the way you do or don't get
their news from the same sources you do
we must end this uncivil war
that pits red against blue
rural versus ireland or rural versus
urban
conservative versus liberal we can do
this
if we open our souls instead of
hardening our hearts
if we show a little tolerance and
humility
and if we're willing to stand in the
other person's shoes as my mom would say
just for a moment stand in their shoes
because here's the thing about life
there's no accounting for what fate will
deal you
some days when you need a hand
there are other days when we're called
to lend a hand
that's how it has to be it's what we do
for one another
and if we are this way our country will
be stronger
more prosperous more ready for the
future
and we can still disagree my fellow
americans
and the work ahead of us we're going to
need each other
we need all our strength to preser to
persevere
through this dark winter we're entering
what may be the toughest and deadliest
period of the virus
we must set aside politics and finally
face this pandemic
as one nation
one nation and i promise you this
as the bible says weeping may endure for
a night
but joy cometh in the morning we will
get through this together together
look folks all my colleagues i serve
with
in the house and the senate up here
we all understand the world is watching
watching all of us today so here's my
message to those beyond our borders
america has been tested and we've come
out stronger for it
we will repair our alliances and engage
with the world once again
not to meet yesterday's challenges but
today's and tomorrow's challenges
and will lead not merely by the example
of our power but by the power of our
example
we'll be a strong and trusted partner
for peace
progress and security
look you all know we've been through so
much in this nation
and my first act as president like to
ask you to join me
in a moment of silent prayer remember
all those who we lost in this past year
to the pandemic
those four hundred thousand fellow
americans
moms dads husbands wives sons daughters
friends neighbors and co-workers we will
honor them
by becoming the people and the nation we
know we can and should be
so i ask you let's say a silent prayer
for those who've lost their lives and
those left behind
and for our country
amen folks
this is a time of testing we face an
attack under democracy
and on truth a raging virus
growing inequity the sting of systemic
racism
a climate in crisis america's role in
the world
any one of these would be enough to
challenge us in profound ways
but the fact is we face them all at once
presenting this nation with the one of
the greatest responsibilities we've had
now we're going to be tested are we
going to step up
all of us it's time for boldness
for there's so much to do and this is
certain
i promise you we will be judged
you and i by how we resolve these
cascading crises of our era
we will rise to the occasion is the
question will we master
this rare and difficult hour when we
meet our obligations and pass along
a new and better world to our children i
believe we must i'm sure you do as well
i believe we will and when we do
we'll write the next great chapter in
the history of the united states of
america the american story
a story that might sound something like
a song that means a lot to me
it's called american anthem
there's one verse that stands out at
least for me
and it goes like this the work and
prayers of century
have brought us to this day what shall
be our legacy
what will our children say let me know
in my heart
when my days are through america
america i gave my best to you
let's add let's us add our own work and
prayers
to the unfolding story of our great
nation
if we do this then when our days are
through
our children and our children's children
will save us
they gave their best they did their duty
they healed the broken land
my fellow americans i closed the day
where i began
with the sacred oath before god and all
of you
i give you my word i will always level
with you
i will defend the constitution i'll
defend our democracy
i'll defend america and i'll give
all all of you keep
everything you i do in your service
thinking not of power but of
possibilities not a personal interest
but the public good and together
we shall write an american story
of hope not fear of unity not division
of light
not darkness a story of decency and
dignity
love and healing greatness and goodness
may this be the story that guides us the
story that inspires us
and the story that tells ages yet to
come
that we answer the call of history we
met the moment
democracy and hope truth and justice
did not die in our watch but thrived
that america secured liberty at home and
stood once again as a beacon to the
world
that is what we owe our forebearers one
another
and generation to follow so
with purpose and resolve we turn to
those tasks
of our time sustained by faith
driven by conviction and devoted to one
another and the country we love
with all our hearts may god bless
america
and may god protect our troops thank you
[Applause]
america
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
garth brooks to perform
amazing grace
uh
[Music]
um
how sweet the
sound then
saved her
[Music]
lost but now
i'm found was blight
but now i
see
[Music]
when we've been
there ten thousand
years bright shining as
the sun
we've known lesson days
to sing god's praise
then when we
first begun
i think ask you to sing this last verse
with me not just the people here
but the people at home that work as one
united oh
may sing grace
how sweet the
sound that saved
a wretch like me
[Music]
i once was lost
but now i'm
found was blind
but now i
[Music]
see
foreign
[Applause]
hard not to be reminded of
hard not to be reminded of president
obama's singing that
same song at the mother emanuel church
a song that in our culture is as close
to both poetry and prayer as you could
possibly
come and we're going to finish with
those two things let me introduce amanda
gorman
our nation's first ever national poet
laureate
[Applause]
mr president dr biden
madam vice president mr
imhof americans and
the world when day comes we ask
ourselves where can we find light in
this
never-ending shade the loss
we carry a sea we must wade we've braved
the belly of the beast
we've learned that quiet isn't always
peace in the norms and notions of what
just is isn't always
just is and yet the dawn is hours before
we knew it somehow we do it somehow
we've
weathered and witnessed a nation
that isn't broken but simply
unfinished we the successors of a
country
in the time were a skinny black girl
descended from slaves and raised by a
single mother
can dream of becoming president
only to find herself reciting for one
and yes we are far from polished
far from pristine but that doesn't mean
we are striving to form a union that is
perfect we are striving to forge
our union with purpose to compose
a country committed to all cultures
colors characters and conditions
of man and so we lift our gazes not to
what stands
between us but what stands before us
we close the divide because we know to
put our future first
we must first put our differences aside
we
lay down our arms so we can reach out
our arms to one
another we seek harm to none and harmony
for all let the globe if nothing else
say this is true
that even as we grieved we grew that
even as we hurt
we hoped that even as we tired we tried
that will forever be
tied together victorious not because we
will never again
know defeat but because we will
never again so division
scripture tells us to envision that
everyone shall sit
under their own vine and fig tree and no
one shall make them
afraid if we're to live up to our own
time
then victory won't lie in the blade but
in all the bridges
we've made that is the promise to glade
the
hill we climb if only we dare it because
being american is more than a pride
we inherit it's the past we step into
and how we repair it we've seen a forest
that would
shatter our nation rather than share it
would destroy our country if it meant
delaying
democracy and this effort very nearly
succeeded but while democracy can be
periodically delayed it can never
be permanently defeated in this truth
in this faith we trust for while we have
our eyes on the future our history
has its eyes on us this is the era of
just redemption we feared it at its
inception we did not feel prepared
to be the heirs of such a terrifying
hour but within it we found the power
to author a new chapter to offer hope
and laughter to ourselves so while
once we asked how could we possibly
prevail
over catastrophe now
we assert how could catastrophe
possibly prevail over us we will not
march back to
what was but move to what shall be a
country that is bruised but
whole benevolent but bold fierce
and free we will not be turned around
or interrupted by intimidation because
we know
our inaction and an ursa will be the
inheritance
of the next generation our blunders
become
their burdens but one thing is certain
if we merge mercy with mites
into mites with rights then love
becomes our legacy and change
our children's birthright so let us
leave behind a country better than one
we were left with
every breath my bronze pounded chest we
will raise this wounded world
into a wondrous one we will rise from
the gold-limbed hills
of the west we will rise from the wind
swept northeast where our forefathers
first
realized revolution we will rise from
the lake rim cities
of the midwestern states we will rise
from the sun baked south we will
rebuild reconcile and recover and every
known nook
of our nation and every corner called
our country
our people diverse and beautiful will
emerge
battered and beautiful when day comes we
step
out of the shade aflame and unafraid the
new dawn blooms
as we free it for there was always light
if only we're brave enough to see it if
only
we're brave enough to be it
thank you amanda gorman now for our
benediction i'm pleased to introduce
reverend dr
sylvester beeman the pastor of the
bethel
african methodist episcopal church in
wilmington delaware
a friend of president biden for 30 years
as a nation and people of faith gathered
in this historical moment
let us unite in prayer
god we gather under the beauty of your
holiness
and the holiness of your beauty we seek
your face
your smile your warm embrace
we petition you once more in this
celebration
we pray for divine favor upon our
president
joseph r biden and our first lady
dr jill biden and their family
we further asked that you would extend
the same
favor upon our vice president
kamla d harris and our second gentleman
doug imhoff and their family
more than ever more than ever
they in our nation need you
we need you for in you we discover
our common humanity in our common
humanity
we will seek out the wounded and bind
their wounds
we will seek healing for those who are
sick and diseased
we will mourn our dead
we will befriend the lonely the least
and the left out
we will share our abundance with those
who are hungry
we will do justly to the oppressed
acknowledge sin and seek forgiveness
thus grasping reconciliation in
discovering
our humanity we will seek the good
in and for all our neighbors
we will love the unlovable remove the
stigma of the so-called untouchables
we will care for our most vulnerable our
children
the elderly emotionally challenged and
the poor
we will seek rehabilitation beyond
correction
we'll extend opportunity to those locked
out of opportunity
we will make friends of our enemies
we will make friends
of our enemies people your people
shall no longer raise up weapons against
one another
we will rather use our resources for the
national good and become a beacon of
life
and good will to the world and neither
shall we learn hatred anymore
we'll lie down in peace and not make our
neighbors afraid in you
oh god we discover our humanity
in our humanity we discover our
commonness
beyond the difference of color creed
origin
political party ideology geography
and personal preferences will become
greater stewards of your environment
preserving the land reaping from it a
sustainable harvest
in securing its wonder and
miracle-giving power
for generations to come this is
our benediction that from
these hallowed grounds
where slaves labored to build this
shrine in citadel
to liberty and democracy let us all
acknowledge
from the indigenous native american
to those who recently received their
citizenship
from the african-american to those whose
four parents came from europe
and every corner of the globe from the
wealthy to those struggling to make it
from every human being regardless of
their choices
that this is our country
as such teachers oh god as such
teach us oh god to live in it
love in it be healed in it
and reconcile to one another in it
lest we miss kingdom's goal
to your glory majesty
dominion and power forever
hallelujah glory
hallelujah and the strong name of our
collective faith
amen
please remain standing as the armed
forces color guard retires our national
colors
[Music]
that's
[Music]
so
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
and remain in your seats while the
president and official party depart the
platform
for safety reasons your ushers will
release your section in an organized
manner
following the playing of our national
march the stars and stripes forever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you